all right jonah yep jonah where'd you
grow up where are you from originally um
around here cross lanes west virginia
you actually live in nitro right yeah
natural
tell me about your childhood had uh both
your parents growing up as a kid um i
lived with my mom until i was seven
six or seven then i moved in with my dad
and was with my dad until
until college
how would you describe your childhood um
it wasn't that bad
um
it was medicated
like adderall and stuff and
i don't know i think that stuff kind of
messed up
my
my life pretty much in what ways like i
don't know i think it kind of feels like
it
made it set in my mind that you have to
be medicated
so like
i don't know so now i have like some
drug problems and stuff and
yeah
how do you describe your childhood
um
i mean it's like a normal childhood
basically um
at first i was like kind of a
troublemaker when i lived with my mom
but then
when i moved in with my dad i really
wasn't much of a troublemaker like
i don't know it's maybe a little bit
suicidal as a child that's that right
like i remember riding my bike into the
road like and every time i'd go to cross
the road i would close my eyes
and i was probably like five or six when
i would do that
which i don't even know why
it was like that like without looking at
yeah the cars were coming without
looking and seeing if cars were coming i
just closed my eyes and just like
kind of hope i make it across wow
and how many times you do that
a few times
and i don't know how i never got hit
like that's just crazy
it blows my mind
this never got hit
it was really strange that's interesting
what are your drugs today
um
heroin
acid that's about it
and that started for you at what age um
20
when i was 20
21
i started off with like painkillers like
the pain pills yeah
this part of the country that's really
how a lot of people started right yeah
painkillers were very popular here back
then
um
which i don't know i kind of have like a
it's a weird theory on it but like
how
i don't know america controls the poppy
fields and
afghanistan and all those places
like
all of a sudden when we got control
those poppy fields like heroin started
flooding
in the states like crazy
and it's kind of like
why is that and then uh
pills were like being
flooded on the streets before then by
doctors and stuff and it's just i don't
know
i always thought that was kind of crazy
like
it seems like they were setting us up
that's interesting
and
i mean does fentanyl make it
down here to appalachia um i believe so
i've uh
i've overdosed like twice this summer
yes i overdosed uh
the ninth of this month
then
june the 13th i overdosed what do you
think you think it might have been from
fentanyl um
i think so because i didn't do that much
and
it was
a small amount
usually i do like i could do a lot more
than that and
in los angeles where i'm from
the heroine is all laced with
fentanyl it's very hard to find heroin
without fentanyl
someone told me the difference on it but
i can't remember
how you could tell
it's by smoking it but
um
i don't smoke it so like i
i never know do you inject it yes
how old do you know i'm 36 36 do you
have kids
yes one kid
and do you are you raising your child um
i'm paying uh
child support
i really don't want to bring him around
into this situation yeah
i'd rather keep him out of it
how do you support yourself um
i hustle here and there
and then
i was working
my uh i got clean there for a while
and then when this virus came around
like i lost my job
and when i lost my job like
i don't know i got like super depressed
and
i just kind of started using again
but i was clean for how did you get
clean
i'm suboxone
and you were clean for hollow
um it was a few months
and like i had no
cravings for it
and uh kratom also
um i had no cravings for heroin
and then uh did the kratom help
yeah it helped a lot and uh
it stops the cravings and it's easier to
get off of than suboxone or
heroin
and you found the crater to help
yeah yeah
but something pushed you to try to go
back to heroin
when when the virus came and hit
i just got into like this depression
because i lost my job
like i had
i had like the best job and like
it was
like a couple things all happened at
once like i had this little kitten
that i was attached to it got killed
um the girl i was seeing
she broke up with me
and then when i went into work to work i
got fired and it was all in one day
and it just kind of like broke me down
so then like
what money i had i went and bought like
five grams of heroin
and just
disappeared for a couple days
um would you say this is the lowest
point in your life right now um yeah
i've never been
like
this low really
as broke as i am like
this virus just totally
ruined my life really
and just i don't know
i felt like
when it was going on and stuff i felt
like
i could tell that life wasn't going to
be the same anymore
and
i don't know
what was the best time in your life
um
um
i'm not for sure
it's been a while since i've had a
a good time of my life
like do you have friends yeah
of your
friends and people your age that you
know how many of them are
addicted to drugs um
i try not to hang out a lot with too
many of them
but there's a few of them um
there's
just a handful of them that are probably
users also and then
but it's very common here yeah
what do you think the cause of
um why are so many people your age
addicted
honestly like
it almost seems like
sometimes it kind of seems like a lot of
people that are addicted to them were
like
had like really bad childhoods like that
were like molested or abused or
some something like that so it helps
them numb the pain
that's what it seems like
because
it's
i don't know i've
a lot of people i've
talked to about like
being abused that are abused abusing uh
heroin and stuff i talk to them and they
say like
basically all the same stuff like
that when they were young that
someone was abusing them and stuff and
which i mean it kind of makes sense like
i don't really hear many people saying
that they were prescribed to something
and then got addicted that way it's
everybody's been
just picked it up
and some of it i think is boredom around
here there's like nothing to do around
here
like
i mean
the concerts like
there wasn't many concerts going on
around here and
and now with kovid there's even less to
do oh yeah
and i know a lot of people that's
that have overdosed recently
and it's
it's kind of crazy one of my friends she
just overdosed
the other day
and
i think she's alive now i'm really not
sure
what emotions do you go through um
usually
depression
like i'm really
depressed a lot but i'm
kind of good at hot in it
when uh when i'm around friends i could
hide it to where because
usually i don't want to talk about it
like i don't like to
have all my business out there like that
because
i don't know
some people
they'll just
i don't know
take advantage i guess
and
i don't know if they found out like what
makes you depressed and you make them
mad one day or so they'll do whatever
they know what makes you depressed and
i don't know
do you think that you have a
self-destructive
oh yeah on the street
the bicycle started when you were young
yeah
um
i never really thought i would live to
be this old actually i always thought i
would kind of died young
which
i know is crazy but
i don't know like
a lot of my heroes like growing up
all kind of died young like said vicious
was one of my heroes or one of the
people i looked up to
and
you know
he died like 21 or something
what do you worry about at this point um
that
um
i'm really not sure um
being homeless basically
worrying about becoming homeless because
around here so many people become
like homeless
and it's so easy to become homeless like
and if you're homeless here in west
virginia
typically what means you find an
abandoned house or um
i'm really not sure what they do like
i've had a lot of friends that would
come and stay with me that were homeless
and there's crashing
and
but like that's probably
the one thing i'm
really afraid of
it's becoming homeless
which i could feel like
i don't know
i almost feel like it's gonna happen
it's just like a matter of time yeah
you're very close to it now
do you have hope for your future
um i wish i did
i really don't at this moment um
i don't know
i've been uh i'm a musician like i play
guitar and stuff and i've been trying to
find a band
and just get in a band and just
travel and do shows which
i know that's
almost like being homeless but
i don't know
i like to travel though
you you were loved in your childhood
you feel right i think so yeah
like my my stepmom wasn't
that nice towards me in the beginning
but then
she became all right
i think at first she just didn't want to
have to deal with raising me
so like
which
she was the reason i got put on a
medication when i was young which i
probably probably needed it because
if i was suicidal at a young age like
i probably needed some kind of
medication but
i mean i almost still feel like i am
every now and then yeah well you're
taking heroin is
you can consider that almost suicidal
yeah
um
the last time i overdosed which was this
month they said uh
i think they said it took eight grams
eight milligrams to bring me back which
i guess that's a lot i'm really not for
sure how the narcotic works huh of the
narcan of the narcan yeah
they said they did two nasal sprays and
then a shot
and
i don't know
when i came back i felt so embarrassed
because like
it's just like waking up basically and
uh
i just like hear the
cops radios and
just see all their feet and it's i don't
know
it's really embarrassing
but
i don't know
the first time i ever did i was
um
it
it was kind of weird that when i came
back i felt really strange
like i felt like i wasn't here anymore
it was really
weird
but they said that uh i had meth in my
system also
oh really
but
i think the person i was with shot me up
with meth like after i overdosed
which was
i don't know
kind of strange
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life um
not to uh
not to have drugs around kids basically
because that first time i overdose
overdosed around a four-year-old
four-year-old child
and it it really like
really hurt my feelings that you know
she she didn't understand what was going
on and she wasn't my child but still
like
it was just
i don't know the child shouldn't have to
see that
all right jonah well thank you so much
for sharing your story
you're welcome i wish you the best of
luck
thank you thanks
you